everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today I'm gonna be going
over Game one 2013 World Chess
Championships between the reigning
champion anon and the highest rated
player in the world and Magnus Carlsen
getting here by winning the candidates
tournament that we covered earlier this
year to give you all some context the
tournament is 12 games along East Side's
will play white and black six games each
respectively each game for the first two
hours or for the first 40 moves they get
two hours after that for the next 20
moves they get an additional hour then
after that they get 15 minutes for the
rest of the game and after each move
they get an additional 30 seconds on the
clock so in the first game we actually
have Magnus Carlsen playing the white
pieces and an odds going to be defending
with the black pieces Magnus Carlsen
decides to start with Knight to f3
they're ready opening really flexible
opening that allows him to go into many
different variations again both of these
players have been preparing many
different openings as far as white as
far as black my English Carlsen likes to
avoid some of the more heavily theorized
openings because he feels like he's just
a better player and so he doesn't want
to go down a path that may be you know a
non or someone else has studied over and
over and over so anon decides to start
with pawn to d5 and then we see Pau and
g3 looking like whites going to
fianchetto his Bishop here to g2 kind of
a hyper modern opening where white looks
to develop his minor pieces really
control the center of the board with his
minor pieces and then later on you know
push forward with his pawns but he's not
gonna do that early on an on defends
with pawn to g6 looking like blacks
going to do the same thing being Kido
doing his own Bishop here on a g7 and we
see that and we see both the ships come
right here and then after the pend
pushing forward to d4 we have pawn c6
and then casting on the King side and
then Knight here to f6 and this really
brings us to you know this is kind of a
grünfeld defense from black very strong
but again it's in my opinion more of a
drama shhhhht offense not really going
to get into any crazy lines that you
really have to figure out okay
what happens if I go down this crazy
path it's pretty straightforward it's
really hard to get out of a line even if
your opponent has prepared something you
know really really juicy for you it's
really hard to fall into some mind trap
so again you know the first game I
personally didn't really expect a lot of
fireworks and so that's kind of what
you're seeing from this opening from
both sides from here Magnus Carlsen
played pawn to b3 getting ready to
fianchetto to the other side although
with this pawn here on d4 looks like
this bishop here on b2 isn't gonna be
doing too much in this game could have
also tried to kind of break things open
played pawn to c4 and kind of wait to
see you know what a Namas gonna play
typically wouldn't take here you know
after the knight here to a3 black
usually just gives back this material
usually doesn't want to play something
you know pawn to b5 trying to hold on to
it really jeopardizing his Queen side
and really you know some of these pawns
are really gonna be a hazard for black
to try to hold on to later in the game
so instead again you know policies for
it's kind of what I was hoping to see
instead we see just this pawn to b3 just
kind of waiting trying to set up all the
pieces for for white as far as minor
pieces and then kind of see what anon
gives him from here is he Castle on the
Kings side obviously want to have your
keening safe and then the bishop coming
here to b2 and then the bishop coming
here to f5 again both sides just trying
to get their minor pieces involved into
the game they don't want to take any
material right now which again it's
pretty common I think for Game one of
the World Chess Championships no one
wants to make a mistake or get into any
crazy lines on the first day take it
pretty easy which as a fan it's not
super exciting but it has to be somewhat
expected if you've seen these kind of
tournaments before we see Magnus Carlsen
respond with pawn to c4 now pushing
forward he does have this extra
protector here with his pawn here on v3
so this makes some sense again this
Bishop Baron b2 isn't doing too much but
it is developed so you know he needs his
knight and his queen developed and then
he has his rooks connected his
development will become
we the night comes here to d7 again once
to complete his development also you
know can't really bring it here to c6
you can now get this Queen involved into
the game you know something c7 makes a
lot of sense usually bring it to b6 if
you have you know a strong attack what
you definitely could you know attacking
this pawn here on d4 y could always just
push forward and kind of make it kind of
awkward for the Queen he just have to
retrieve back but he could kind of force
a knot or force Carlsen to go ahead and
push his pawn if if you wanted it to
come there we now see the knight coming
here to c3 you know again this is kind
of a safe move I think Magnus Carlsen
had a few other options he could have
played Knight here to h4 kind of forcing
the action with the bishop most players
don't want to give up their bishops
early on it to the game especially for a
trade even though the bishop and the
knight are both three points you usually
don't see high-level players you know
giving up their bishops for eight knight
and so you know the bishop could come
back here to e6 and then you know even
Knight here to d2 you could also see the
Queen you know here to see to this is
pretty good but again both these options
give white you know a little bit more of
the lead as far as the tempo you know
kind of they're they're kind of leading
the charge right now Knight to c3 again
I think it's just kind of a safe move I
don't really foresee any fireworks going
on in the middle here which we'll see
later on but again just kind of showing
you some of the the other variations
that as we were kind of going through
this game we kind of saw so from here
anon decides to go ahead and take and
then after the recapture we see the
knight come here to b6 again attacking
this pawn on c4 this pawn definitely
needs to to move forward to kind of stop
being attacked and so the knight comes
here to c4 and this is a nice little
square for this night because it's kind
of an outpost usually you have a Knights
at an outpost being protected by a pawn
but in this case there's no pawns that
can really attack it this this
LightSquared bishop right here on g2
it's never really gonna come over here
for a long time to threaten it so really
this is kind of an outpost here for the
night now white can really threaten this
if he gets this Queen
involved up right now this night can
just kind of hang out and see what
magnus carlsen does this nights also
attacking the bishop here on v2 White
has a few options you could always play
you know Queen here to be three
attacking this knights more than likely
and now I'm gonna just go ahead and take
the bishop again I think this would be
fine for whites but again usually you
don't see players giving up their bishop
for at night so this particular game we
see magnus carlsen just bring his bishop
back here to see one again kind of just
doodling around with his bishop back
here not doing too much now the knight
comes here to d5 I think it probably
would have been more pressing for non to
try for Knight here to e4 it does keep
this D file open you know he does have
the Queen right here so he can really
put a lot of pressure on this pawn here
on d4 but again this is going to be a
more complex line than just coming here
to d5 kind of locking up this B file and
again in my opinion going to agerola
Stipe of game and that's kind of what we
see especially the first game if you're
playing is black knowing that if you
draw this entire tournament you still
regain the championship
there's no reason right now for a non to
get out of the line because he
recognizes that his opponent has you
know the in game figured out maybe
better than anyone right now he's a
young guy with stamina so why use a lot
of energy in Game one so he does decide
to play this Knight to d5 and then we
see the Queen come here to b3 attacking
this night so the knight has to move
that comes back here to a5 and again we
are now 13 moves in and unfortunately
the game is pretty much over we now see
the Queen come back here to a3 and then
the knight back here to c4 and then
we're just gonna repeat moves and the
game actually ends in a draw just a
couple moves later on threefold
repetition and so we could see something
different you know after the knight
comes here we could eventually see the
Queen come back here to be too you know
but again the knight can just come back
here to c4 the Queen can't take here on
b7 because again this night would just
fall right here on c3 so in the
particular game we just see
both these pieces just going back and
forth and on the sixteenth move both
players shook hands and it was a drawl
so in my opinion not the most exciting
game it lasts 16 moves but because of
the revolved threefold repetition really
only lasted about 14 so definitely not
the fireworks I was hoping for but
definitely the game that I somewhat
expected so game one was a draw and next
game an on will be playing the white
pieces and hopefully we have something
more exciting so check back here we're
gonna be doing commentary for all of the
games for the 2013 World Championship so
hope you guys enjoy and I'll see you on
the next video
thanks for watching